to get whatever in your safe they place
you on the stretcher i'm from the east
side of buffalo well there ain't no
beaches over there ain't no peace just
little [__] airing pieces gotta keep
your pistol on you everywhere and don't
leave it squeeze it every situation
gotta carefully weed it my name is very
prestigious machine [__] audio heroine
leaking through the bluetooth stereo
speakers i mean you see i overcame being
paraplegic so calling me out boy that
[__] is clearly egregious [__] it's the
drum work boss the faith i put this nine
to your back like the olympic journal in
seattle it ain't no raffle alive that
could [__] with me on this best day this
[__] is chess play after my next tape
that [__] is checkmate
after the tech spray that hit your chest
plate and that's your death date i had
to check take off i have a fresh plate
of what the private chef make machine
[__] y'all [__] have a blessed day
i'm gone
[Music]
have a blessed [__] day man
have a blessed day
the 25th february 25th man god don't
make mistakes